Hollywood is making a big-budget film
about Noah and his ark you sure about
that yeah yeah and everyone some that
the movie has not been released yet but
like most films that involve the Bible
there's already a controversy really
yeah according to The Hollywood Reporter
focus groups really didn't like the
ending to this Noah movie they showed it
to them and they got they just did not
like it Wow and so I was really curious
I was able to see the ending of the
movie well I was able to watch it I have
to say the blood was in my pants
[Music]
that's the worst ending to a movie I've
ever seen I don't think that's the way
it happens in the book either no and the
way the credits just fly by yeah that's
insanity can't read any don't even know
who that actor is he's not famous what a
stupid waste of everyone's time
[Laughter]
hang in there yeah I'm here